hey long as you want it what's going on
man oh you know just in the round oh
cool the landline ministry closes 52
Jesus we ended 43 see very many men have
been very stressful your make this count
okay I didn't see um a lot of aggressor
linked to it what it's called I don't
feel at home in this world anymore it's
a comedy yeah thriller and it's on
Netflix and they didn't they don't move
it so it's linked if they did not intend
to either one of us but I'll tell you
this I'm assuming they probably didn't
because it's available tomorrow and
Netflix right it's gotten it's getting
like super like good reviews already won
awards oh yeah we won the Grand Jury
Prize at something were you kidding me I
mean you're laughing I'm assuming you
did not know no we didn't which isn't
which isn't to say that we don't love
the film and believe in it I don't think
you ever anticipate those kinds of
things happening in Sundance you know
octone was a dark comedy that kind of
gets into genre territory towards the
end it gets very intense
not the kind of film typically to win
the Grand Jury Prize you know these are
the birth of a nation so the kinds of
films that tend to win that prize so is
a real surprise but you know we were
trapped I always expect things I do to
win I'm always in fact it's never done
shooting I'm like here come the award
nothing well if I like it
every everyone's gonna worship is that
scenarios like that where like you love
something and you're like dishes like
the one this is my thing and then it
fails
yeah people just don't respond to it um
I don't know I tend to operate from a
relatively humble place so I never have
I also don't really believe in
expectations so I don't enter into
anything with any expectations so even
if I love something you know I don't
know I feel like its life reveals what
it's going to do if that makes sense
you're right you get a sense of where
something's going to go and how it will
be received I don't know that I've ever
been horribly wrong where I've been like
oh man this thing's really great nobody
likes it I don't know I keep relatively
reasonable expectations what do you
think about this whole sorry anything
about this whole explosion of
everybody's talking about you talked
about it last year everybody's talking
about this 13 year old boys and sex and
all this and now it's in the four five
of the culture every day you turn
everyone is talking about somebody
else's trying yet it was so satisfying
shocking why defy it's crazy yeah what's
the funny thing is that that whole thing
as it pertains to me came out of an
interview where someone just asked for
my comments on it as it pertains to sort
of molestation in Hollywood I have no
personal experience with it so I was
literally speaking from someone that is
as knows as much about it as any of you
do and you know for documentaries and
stuff it got misconstrued in in the
press as if I was some sort of
ambassador with a great deal of
knowledge as to what's going on I really
don't the good thing about it is that it
created a conversation and it seems to
have not stopped it's got a lot of legs
which is great there's obviously a lot
of people with more first-hand knowledge
and I suppose they're the ones which
should be doing the talking it's so
weird to which was like it Milo now the
Liberals are going after a lot of
conservatives now George Takei the
Conservatives are going up it's like
ours now be no more it's not being
taught everyone just targets people on
one basis basis of like political
ideology that's [ __ ] crazy no there's
no there's no morality it's just like
whatever your politics are you look back
you and I have to attack him in getting
this person then they are actually they
don't care about what's right or wrong
can we use this to get you right I know
we're in a very strange divisive time in
the sense that a Republican will attack
a Democrat simply because he or she is a
Democrat and the same on the other side
and that's not really getting us
anywhere but I actually thought you know
I don't agree at all with Milo's
politics but I thought it was good
to have him on Bill Maher show I think
you know the the unfortunate thing with
that happened at Berkeley where there
was sort of these almost riots as a
result of Berkeley accepting Milo at the
campus it's really the wrong way to go
like we need to be able to hear the
opinions of people we don't agree with
and give them a platform so that we can
have we can hear that side and
articulate why we think it's not great
more of that less of the shutting people
down with opinions that we don't agree
with because when you're living in Italy
you just make the conscious decision
and you can now like either side not
like liberal and conservative but it's
so easy to just choose to live in a
bubble because there are quarterly news
sources that will just say what you want
yeah here and your Twitter feed yeah
yeah and so yeah I do find it odd that
more and more it seems like people are
making that choice to like live in the
bubble and be like wow no I don't agree
with that so I'm going to find an
article that I do agree with instead of
being like let me juggle some things
here let me figure out where in the
middle or what the truth is sure on
these two sides sure it's easy to do and
it's also to some degree I think we're
all guilty of it because we tend to
follow people that we agree with or yeah
voices that we respect which tends to
reinforce our political perspectives and
it's hard it's hard to find unbiased
news you know it's not easy to find a
source because the other side of it is
of a gear if you're a Democrat or you're
you know you're liberal
do you go to Breitbart to read their
news well that's going to be relatively
biased views oh yeah it's a struggle you
know it's you kind of want the sources
to be as unbiased as possible and that's
very difficult to find everyone thinks
that were the most unbiased people's
like we all think that we're reasonable
well you asked me do I think I'm an
unreasonable [ __ ] there's no as the
perfect ballot and every person I know I
know it's true and that's a real liberal
thing because liberals think they're
very reasonable and I agree I think they
are you know there's so many things
separating liberals and conservatives
I think liberals would say that they
they operate from a standpoint of reason
and logic I think that more often than
not that's true but they're guilty the
same [ __ ] yeah it also seems like
there's like a moral high ground yet a
lot of liberals tend to take where they
feel like their side is the right side
like not correct and I can be very
isolating yes that can be very isolating
especially to middle America people with
more conservative values and beliefs
that can that can make people feel less
than and make people feel attacked like
well that means that what I'm doing is
wrong yeah like you're telling like I
thought I was doing the right ways they
learn to listen listen to learn and I
should bumper stickers that says it's an
important lesson it is important thank
you very much it's really really
up with these catchy little things that
really help you it's just well thought
out and yeah it's got a lot of levels to
it it's not come on it's really not
right at all you know learn listen
listen learn several where you want to
put it yeah it's it's a crazy time we're
living in another it's a this is usually
do you get in unless identity do you
read a lot of stuff you keep up on the
news you try to jump into work instead
mm-hmm no I try to it's sort of
unavoidable because it's so batshit
crazy it's like watching a terrible
reality program or something it doesn't
feel doesn't feel very presidential or
professional it just seems like you
don't want to see like there's chaos
oh yeah highway is good though
personality I don't know she's she's
smart she's a lot of really cool [ __ ]
what you're taking a break from media
yes which is really good what wasn't she
like a senior adviser to him and now
they're not what they're doing
everything well that's right that's good
i I'm convinced though I saw him she was
on Fox News this morning and I'm
convinced that somebody does that was
real that [ __ ] were like you know what
we're gonna put the brakes on her but it
was private and then the news reported
it they're like okay put her on Fox News
then we can take that with fake news Wow
I'm convinced of it yeah you know yeah
expense yeah those denies being
sidelined see I really want to [ __ ] her
really yeah I just something sexy about
her and hits the angry thing well I'm
not mad at her I would love to just [ __ ]
her I think that should be awesome she
probably a big submissive dominant
personality got another side Oh would I
kiss her feet give her a [ __ ]
spanking you want all right straighten
her right out yeah yeah maybe that's
what she need yeah I like this great
thing about Norton is that like but it's
not about like oh you know I hate her
politics so much I want to like sleep
with her because I'm angry it's know you
could take you could take the politics
out and just be like no no I want to
[ __ ] her she's attractive yeah yeah but
um politics well that's good yeah you
don't discriminate I like it that's
that's where Jim's being a reasonable
that's right he is he absolutely and
politics don't matter to them right with
the promise nobody has friends like you
we talked about when you know certain
actors or celebrities have said things
and a lot of times they don't have
friends that will just go shut up like
you really need Peep
around you and who care about you enough
to just debate you in real life yes yeah
and a lot of people don't have that
because they're so powerful they're in
such high esteem they don't have friends
that will go what the [ __ ] are you
talking about so they say these things
publicly and they wonder why everybody
reacts like they're [ __ ] that's it
because no one in your personal life
ever told you you sound stupid when you
sit and it goes back to the news think
if they surround themselves with that
thing of agree ability yeah it's a
little easier and more pleasant on a day
to day basis if you're sure right 100%
of the time sure people need checks and
balances yeah I think that's people need
people around them to tell them that
they're [ __ ] up yeah making choices
that aren't great choices and you know
that's what true friends do now having
people around you that say that you're
perfect or you know agree with
everything that you're saying is is a
terrible situation are you in
relationship recycle I'm not in a
relationship how long eight months okay
so it's all kind of this you still like
a not fighting place you're in that like
ya know fall fresh no fight yes nice
yeah yeah that's it always I was that
literally talking to somebody they were
in a much newer relationship yesterday
and they were talking about when do we
tell people blah blah blah and I'm very
new yeah they were like yes like
probably like two months in and it's a
they're somewhat public so it's like it
might be a thing when they would be
there but I know you were ready I'm not
good but I was like you guys got to make
my advice was to have your first fight
before you tell people because you do
have to do something to wipe the
honeymoon stage out and survive it right
more like because otherwise it's a thing
if god forbid it does right now that's
what I feel sure my forever friend and
then all of a sudden like yeah we
survived it that's a good idea I also
think you know intrinsically whether
something's going to go the distance or
be something that you're investing what
will be a lot of time into yeah but yeah
I suppose I mean I've added why do I
love yeah Wow yeah yeah once I feel like
I've been like head over heels and then
three months later like look at them
like I who are you yeah so I have no
feeling and you have you have thank you
miss your emails that are over your head
that doesn't happen yeah and I'm like I
should why did I say all those things
about loving the
their answer I don't feel that way at
all exactly she has great nipples okay
they're all is that a pattern is that
just one day well I mean I'm married now
so it's not but it was like I found
myself in a series of short
relationships is doing that are just
like yeah and then oh yeah we have to
and very shortly we because it's not
that we want to but it's a computer
issue I don't feel at home in this wiki
they cut us off and I don't feel at home
in this world anymore is available
exclusively on Netflix
yep the computers aren't all bad they
brought us Netflix there you go yeah and
you know analysers film is doing very
very well it's on Netflix tomorrow by
the way I don't feel at home in this
world anymore it's gotten amazing
reviews and yeah and it's grand anse
jury award congratulations thank you
really great yeah thanks man I hope you
guys see the film and I hope you enjoy i
well i wish we could have seen it before
they'd have been prepared i would have
talked about it I would give it away
certain scenes maybe it's all for the
better than I know and yeah man thanks a
lot thanks dude and we'll see you guys
tomorrow unless we're done oh my god
over